some stunning video out of ohio we want
to show you a police officer's dashboard
camera
capturing the moment he and some
bystanders pulled an unconscious driver
out of a wrecked vehicle
this all happened about an hour east of
cleveland
the rescue was made even more dramatic
when the car burst into flames
warren ohio police officer dave weber
rushed to the scene of a car accident
wednesday
he's in a vehicle he went off the road
into bushes
and he's shaking i could see him when
webber approached the car
he found the driver unresponsive behind
the wheel
as the suv began to smoke
according to the warren police
department the car caught on fire
while webber was still inside flames
shooting out the rear passenger door
forcing webber to jump out of harm's way
but the driver's front door was opened
with the help of good samaritans
allowing the driver to be pulled to
safety one of those good samaritans
was thomas cool the police officer went
in the car
first he cut the seat belt and then we
were both
able to pull him out so yeah the officer
really did the most he
like i said his pant legs were on fire
and he really
the warren police really did a great job
here bystanders say the driver appeared
to have had a medical emergency when he
was behind the wheel
his foot was still on the gas pedal
because we could hear the engine
revving as we walked up with the vehicle
catching fire
if he would have still been in there
obviously when it turned out as well as
it did
the man was taken to an area hospital
for treatment
cool says it was simply instinct to help
it's always helped people if they're
hurting yeah that's all
unbelievable nothing more inspiring to
see willing to sacrifice your life to
save someone else
i think so often we forget there are
officers every day who can do cross
situations exactly right
exactly and yeah just acting it's
instinct